[Music]
play a Navy SEAL in this movie and and
everyone knows if you're you're playing
someone on not just a Navy SEAL SEAL
Team six yeah which is you studied this
the ultimate elite of the elite of the
elite
yeah seal SEAL Team six is essentially
the all-star team of the SEAL Teams
becoming a Navy Seal and and I mean in
real life not as an actor but you know
in the the guys who do this are so fit
they are just they go through incredibly
grueling physical and mental torture in
order to to become a seal and once they
get on the SEAL Teams and they're on
their operating as a team guy then the
very best of them are brought together
to to what was a visually originally
called a dev group which is like a
development group and this is like Tier
one SEAL Team six they're the badasses
they're the guys who get brought in to
do all the really I mean they're all
badass but these are this is a really
very slow they have a lead on Osama bin
Laden's whereabouts these are the guys
who go in yeah and and did go in and
we're glad they did but what's amazing
is you yourself had to get in sick shape
yeah yeah because um I don't know if you
can tell from the angle right now but
I'm kind of like extra bellied going on
that's for it was having a nervous
breakdown or it's it for a role that was
for a role well I originally I but I've
always been a little soft I like to eat
now it's like - I'm not crunches I'm not
gonna do but I had a deadline to play a
SEAL Team six members so I got and I had
about five or six months and I just
really busted my ass to get in good
shape and then after I wrapped the movie
almost immediately I gained like 60
pounds to play role in another 60
because you had to play a heavier guy
kind of despondent emasculated character
that was like fat and an unhappy I have
before and after pics we have before and
after pictures this is you as the seal
and then this is you very shortly after
[Applause]
that's amazing yeah that's your before
and after pictures aren't showing like
that no that's the first time we can
take you from this to this to that other
guy yeah that's incredible we have a
clip here from zero dark thirty I think
I know which scene this is I think this
is when you're when you're finding out
the that that it might be a go yeah this
is us hanging out at hanging out in a
you know Forward Operating Base
incidentally we're 15 miles from the
Syrian border where we shot this it was
a super scary place to be but we were
there and we shot it and this is the
SEAL team and they you know who are you
really quickly the the movie chronicles
really the pursuit of Osama bin Laden
yeah and this one woman who has this
real devotion and sense that I think we
can get him and then finally you get to
the part in the movie
she's been waiting and waiting and
waiting and we find out that it's gonna
be a go and you're on the team
yeah and I'm part of the team that's
gonna you know that that takes him down
and kills him let's let's take a look at
this clip from zero dark thirty
[Music]
so Patrick be honest with me
you really believe this story
I mean no offense no offense I don't but
Osama bin Laden
yeah well Parker mystery
her conference
yeah ayah I wanted you to hear it first
you know anything we talked about it's
gonna happen tonight
[Music]
no spoilers we won't tell you what
happens but